hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move university comm
thank you and enjoy now that we've
discussed the short-term control it's
discussed the long-term control which
cream which involves controlling
transcription translation and
proteolysis so let's start with
transcription so at the transcriptional
level basically the idea is to control
the rate at which the HMG co-reductase
mRNA is made right transcription so
before we can actually discuss the
mechanism by which that happens we have
to get past some terminology first so
we'll start off with sree sree is the
sterile regulatory element which is a
DNA sequence and because the DNA
sequence location is in the nucleus of
the cell okay and there's also the srebp
which is the sterile regulatory element
binding proteins so it's a transcription
factor that actually binds that DNA
sequence and specifically it's an
activator of transcription and thus it
will increase the transcription of the
genes coding for enzymes involved in
cholesterol synthesis specifically HMG
co-reductase so it increase the
transcription of the the gene for that
reductase and this binding protein is
located in its Indy endoplasmic
reticulum membrane and the last thing
here is the SCA V or SCAP and it is the
srebp cleavage and activating proteins
so the S is is all of this here this
this S represents this whole thing and
then c.a.p
cleavage and activating protein so it's
all membrane protein also embedded in
the ER membrane and what it does is
pretty important it senses and responds
to cholesterol levels
okay so it's it's kind of the well I
guess we'll just see here so in Scenario
one imagine that cholesterol levels are
low
okay so let's hear this little four ring
structure here represents cholesterol is
only one of them cholesterol levels are
low so that's sensed by the SCAP protein
and they can cleave and activate srebp
because because the cholesterol levels
are low we need to make more right and
we can make more by having an increase
of transcription of the reductase and of
the reductase gene so that we can have
more mRNA that we can translate into
protein so SCAP rent recognizes that
there's a low amount of cholesterol and
what it'll do is it'll trigger the
migration of the SCAP protein and as
well as the srebp to the golgi okay and
it'll be modified there and you'll might
be wondering what the C and the N are
the C's is the carboxy terminal domain
of the srebp and the n is the amino
terminal and so we go to the golgi for
modification then what happens is that
the scat protein will trigger its first
cleavage of the srebp so it's good it's
a cleave and activate the sra TPP so as
a first cleavage that cuts off a certain
portion of it and then there's a second
cleavage that Cleaves off specifically v
the amino terminal portion and in that
amino terminal portion is released into
the cytosol and it is it eventually goes
into the nucleus and binds the sre binds
the sre in the nucleus to increase
transcription and then we get more
reductase mrna that we can that we can
transcribe forcing me to translate into
the protein so then we have more of this
reductase so we end up making more
cholesterol okay that's one scenario
that's a scenario when cholesterol
levels are low now what if cholesterol
levels are high
if cholesterol levels are high then the
high levels of cholesterol are sensed by
the SCAP and the migration of the Golgi
for modification does not even happen
right because we do not want to end up
transcribing the reductase to make more
cholesterol if we already have plenty of
it if the viceroy levels are high we
need to we need to not make any so do
not make more so we're not going to go
through and follow through with the
transcription of this gene if we've
already got plenty of cholesterol around
we don't need more reductase to make
more of it so none of this stuff that
follows would occur when the cholesterol
levels are high
it's only when cholesterol levels are
low that we're good that the SCAP will
go ahead and activate the srebp allow it
to by the sre to have more transcription
occur make more reductase and as an
extension of course more cholesterol so
that's the transcriptional level let's
look at the translational level and the
proteolytic level starting with the
translational level so translation
basically we're going to take this
reductase transcript and translate it to
the actual enzyme right the protein this
is inhibited by a couple things it's
inhibited by dietary cholesterol that
should make sense it's just the idea
that if we've already got cholesterol
let's not make this enzyme that'll make
more of it another thing is that there
are non sterile metabolites that follow
mevalonate in the cholesterol synthesis
pathway that will also inhibit this we
mentioned before that methyl on it was
the committed molecule to cholesterol
synthesis so metabolites that follow it
in the pathway that are after it they
can come by basically they're an
indication that we're making cholesterol
so they can come by and inhibit
translation so that we don't make more
of this reductase that we'll end up
making more methyl on a and more of
those metabolites which are heading
towards cholesterol
so it makes sense then that those guys
would all inhibit the translation of
this reductase transcript and in the
proteolytic level is last so we have HMG
co-reductase here and it has its
embedded in the ER membrane it's got a
membrane domain here and it's got a
cytosolic domain that actually does the
conversion of hmg-coa into mevalonate so
that's the cytosolic domain there so the
cytosolic domain carries out the actual
catalysis by converting hmg-coa to metal
on a then in the committed step and then
there's a membrane domain this membrane
domain contains a sterile sensing domain
so it detects sterile levels so if the
sterile concentration is increasing or
increases too much then the hmg-coa
reductase is you Bick whatin Aidid
ubiquitinated and protea lies it's
broken down because if there's a bunch
of stare all around we don't need to
make more right so those are three
different levels long term that a three
levels of control long-term that
determine whether or not this reductase
is even available for catalytic activity
so I hope that video was helpful in
summarizing the long term control thank
you for watching
thanks for watching and be sure to LIKE
comment subscribe and share the video
with anyone you think might find it
helpful thanks happy studying